tonight would begin a week-long analysis
of one of the most controversial
political manifestos to emerge in quite
some time freshmen New York
congresswoman self-described socialist
Alexandra Acacio Cortez has come up with
something called the green New Deal we
should note Massachusetts Democrat
Senator Ed Markey also made the original
green New Deal pitch but the only thing
turning green right now seems to be
other Democrats forced to defend a
strategy that even some in the
mainstream media are mocking
correspondent Doug mackelway begins our
reporting never in our history have the
interest of all Americans been so United
if unity about climate change ever
existed within moments of the green New
Deal rollout it tore apart two days
before this press conference
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortez
posted a green new deal FAQ segment on
her website referencing the alleged ten
years that mankind has to save the earth
the Post said quote we aren't sure that
we'll be able to fully get rid of
farting cows and airplanes that fast it
also promised quote economic security
for all unable or unwilling to work a
torrent of ridicule followed well if the
green New Deal took hold our I think our
grid would stop it sounds like a high
school term paper that got a low mark
within hours of Cascio Cortez's office
deleted the faq from her website the
following Saturday her chief of staff
tweeted it was an early draft posted by
a mistake the night before an advisor to
Ocasio Cortez offered a different
explanation no no she's actually tweeted
it out to laugh at it if you look at her
latest tweets it seems that apparently
some Republicans have put it out there
the Cornell professor was mistakenly
referring to a parody of the FAQ tweeted
by right-wing commentator mark dice dice
inserted into the real documented
guarantee for massage chairs and a call
for American men to recycle urine Mitch
McConnell well known for his disdain of
show votes announced a show vote see how
they feel about the green
New Deal this cheap cynical ploy
evidently represents the sum total of
Senate Republicans leadership on the
vital issue of climate change sixty
seven Democrats signed onto the green
new deal including many presidential
candidates yet stung by the ridicule
many tempered their support why not have
an aspirational goal aspirational is a
vague term for a vague non-binding
resolution the rest of this week will
try to pin down the real costs and
consequences of the green new deal right
Doug thank you